got this tweet from Liz Harrington at
realiz USA president Trump raised over
four million dollars in 24 hours after
indictment in Alvin Bragg Witch Hunt
over 25 percent of donations came from
first-time donors to the Trump campaign
and that right there
can I just I just want everyone to to
figuratively gloat over this as I will
now rub it in the face of that Politico
reporter who said Donald Trump will not
earn a single new voter from this
indictment don't overthink it the
indictment is bad for Trump and I'm just
like bro he just he's got new voters
right here literally literally right
here more money pouring in this is what
they asked for I have to wonder if
they're like act if they really do want
Trump to be in office because the media
knows that when he's when he's in office
they make money well I think there's a
stupid narrative that I want to debunk
real quick that was being pushed by a
lot of folks who don't want to see Trump
uh be the Republican nominee they say
the Democrats are indicting Trump and
trying to throw him in jail because they
want him to win now they are trying to
throw him in jail because they're
absolutely terrified that he is going to
win
um but you know I'm glad you putting out
those statistics a fourth of the new
donors are first-time Trump donors these
like normal people are watching what's
taking place normal people are watching
Joe Biden throw wrote grandmas who
brought Trump Flags to the Capitol in
jail they're watching Joe Biden throw a
guy who made a meme of Hillary Clinton
in jail and now they're going to watch
them throw the Pres you know president
Trump uh you're trying to throw him
behind bars or watching this and they
think this is disgusting how could this
ever happen to our country and a lot of
folks who came over here as immigrants
from countries like Cuba or a lot of
these Guatemala they fled corrupt
regimes like this they don't want this
to come if they if this happens the
United States of America there's nowhere
else for anybody to go El Salvador
it means the Savior and that's kind of
funny but up until uh naively I think I
think pronouncing it wrong up until like
he got in and started reforming it
especially with Bitcoin there I would
have said no other country and I'm kind
of like Al Salvador's doing pretty well
but but for the most part in terms of
the wealth the access the opportunity El
Salvador is doing fantastic
so it's like okay I like it but let's be
real the United States is like supposed
to be the Bastion of freedom and if it
falter is here having to retreat to the
next best thing is still a loss it's the
loss of of the best absolutely I've got
this feeling
oh holler El Salvador what's happening
boo Kelly uh I I support the presidency
I'm not into like do I support Trump do
I support Biden like look I will work
with anyone that wants to bring Liberty
to the world and but I think all of us
should be supporting the office I got
the individuals I got a problem with
that that that verbiage bring bring
Liberty to the world that sounds a whole
lot like George Bush man no like that's
a sporting you you can't export liberty
no you know sure you can build free
software that lets people gov themselves
yeah but but come on like also realize
if we blow up all their kids then their
kids will be free from being alive yeah
so when I know George W bush what I
literally I'll explain what I literally
mean
but I mean that we could build software
that we utilize in the United States so
that people can govern themselves
locally Liberty Liberty is Liberty is
just like you can lead a horse to water
but you can't make them drink you cannot
make people want to be free if people
want a Theocratic government there and
you give them Liberty they're going to
give themselves a Theocratic government
but if people have technology that is
muting their ability to see the real
world and then you give them what do you
mean see the real world like Tick Tock
the algorithm is making them see what
the CCP wants them to see so if we can
give them technology where they can see
reality a little more clearly I mean
people choose Liberty do you I don't
know that's true I I I think
when when you give people the ability to
see the world you end up with
let's put it this way I think there was
a uh I believe in free speech I believe
in transparency but I do think it could
go either way you give people absolute
freedom and then they might just become
gluttonous there needs to be moral
foundations we agree upon where we have
limits that's why we have borders I
think one of the problems we had as a
country is
too much of the country became Live and
Let Live and there there needs to be two
forces of pushing and pulling where one
group challenges that one group is
holding everything back saying no no we
shouldn't change it the other group says
I hereby challenge you we go to court we
determine okay this was good that was
bad and that's how we progress properly
but what happened is the the
conservative chain was broken and the
left just zoomed full speed off into I'm
gonna do whatever I want with no
restrictions and now you end up with
child sex changes we need a strong
Republic that's the Restriction force is
the Congress and the Senate you know the
house and honestly the executive branch
has an opportunity to be a stop Gap with
the veto power
um I don't like seeing things rushed
through so I would encourage I think
actually that we are technocracy whether
we want to admit it or not that we've
become a technocratic republic and if we
don't start creating a technocratic
republic like we want to see it it's
going to be created for us in a way that
we don't like Alex I wanted to follow up
with you with something we touched on
that you kind of touched on with this
indictment and it was kind of the
political ramifications for it and what
the Democrats like a cynical Democratic
operative might be trying to pull
together here with um with this
indictment that would make it more
popular among the base but what would
you say to a like a cynical Democrat
operative who might say that Trump might
be more palatable now in a primary
because of this but in a general he
would be less palatable to Suburban
white women than maybe Iran DeSantis
would against the Joe Biden well new
polling just came out today uh done by
uh the people's pundit Barris I think
he's a really smart guy that had Trump
winning with women 52-19 against Ron
DeSantis you know I took my mom to meet
Trump wow in August at a rally in
Wisconsin and the first thing my mom
says to Trump is
you know Mr President I had a crush on
you in the 80s like there's a lot of
women my mom's age that remember Donald
Trump from the 80s and they loved the
guy when everybody loved the guy when
everybody was allowed to love the guy uh
and president Trump does very well with
you know with the ladies um you know the
the pageants he used to own the pageants
and what happened to the pageants what
about with Independence though that was
so the polls I've been seeing show that
random sentence does better well there's
there's some polls that he does better
there's some polls that he doesn't a lot
of the polls that the DeSantis team
likes to tout are paid for polls a guy
named Chris Wilson with WPA Intel he's
notorious do you think calls Donald
Trump would be more palatable in a
general election to moderates than uh I
do I think that the a lot of I mean how
many folks in here voted for for Trump
in 2020. Trump I did not vote I would
have Trump you vote for Trump I didn't
vote either no how do you how do you
view the
uh indictment of him and the fact that
they're trying to throw him in jail
well I don't I don't I don't like the
idea I don't like the precedent of
taking down past past presidents because
then the next president's going to take
down past presidents then the one after
that's going to take down the one before
it is Trump just has so much baggage
though relatively this is the argument
widely though sorry but that's that's
good I appreciate that point and then my
I want to follow up
um would you rather have Rhonda Sanders
or Donald Trump oh I need to I this is
this is why we have two years to
campaign I want to talk to both of them
and have deep conversations about
technology and their Visions for the
future I got a decision so would you be
able to say like right now based on what
you know is there One Direction you lean
towards I know a lot of Trump's friends
like I know a lot of people that work
with them in forum and but I I don't
like when they're like they'll call him
the boss because the boss is the
American people and we need to serve the
office all of us they do well we've also
had a lot of DeSantis friends on I mean
I don't know what how do you lean or are
you neutral on the two of them I'm very
neutral I mean does the indictment turn
you off from Trump no no no and I think
that's a sentiment that's across the
country like this real quick I just
think everybody who knows the show and
knows Ian that his input on this is
valuable right the Ian's got like a
weird political stance that's not hyper
hyper like
it's not the same as all of us who are
clearly on a track and have views like
feels very libertarian I'm pretty
Centrist you know moderate you're very
conservative Ian's the Wild Card who
often defends Democrats in ways we don't
agree with so I think your inputs it's
very valuable to me right now like you
don't know between the two I think that
says a lot but also the fact that you're
saying that this indictment of him like
doesn't make you reject him and like
you're you're not even thinking about
that I think most people are exhausted
by the that the Democrats have
put the country through for seven years
Witch Hunt after Witch Hunt after Witch
Hunt into president Trump from uh the
moment he came down the escalator the
the Mueller hoax the Ukraine hoax the
um you know uh the January 6th the list
goes on and people are just exhausted
and they're throwing him in jail over a
a personal payment I guess how would you
respond to people who say that he has a
lot more baggage than DeSantis does and
that would turn off wait let me go over
it would be like January 6th
and then not also not pardoning January
6th prisoners um I'll just look at the
camera when I say this you just don't
know Rhonda Santos's baggage yet and
believe me there's a lot of material
there and I kind of feel like he's he's
more likely to compromise and I feel
like Trump is more likely to enact
Revenge I mean and I don't mean that I
don't mean that in a biblical sense I
mean it more like a I'm not listening to
you I'm done with you you wasted my time
you're fired whereas the sentence is
going to be like let's try and work
together to make a better it seems like
we're like tipping over the edge of the
liberal economic order into the New
World Order and we have an opportunity
to unify and create the New World Order
In Like An American Image where we have
like localized government property
rights free speech gun control gun well
gun rights and things like that and and
if we fight and argue as Americans then
it'll be the world economic Forum that
builds it for us and then we'll be all
like still and then we'll be arguing
with them and we'll be all trained to
argue so I really want someone that can
unify and not unify out of fear unify
out of love and like a vision for
reality like a growth pattern well in a
weird way I think on Tuesday our country
is going to be more unified than ever
before even though we're going to seem
so incredibly divided but when there's
the photographs of the former president
of the United States and the leading
opponent to the current president when
they're walking him into a jail
to try to you know book him that's going
to bring people together people don't
understand like he's going into a
holding cell yeah like when he goes in
I'm like typically when you're arrested
you get placed in holding it's not like
a jail where they lock you in to punish
you it's like we're temporarily placing
you here as we process your paperwork
how are they going to do that it's
terrible but they're going to do it but
but a secret service goes in there with
them oh absolutely and they're going to
protect the guys this is great and
that's gonna be on Tuesday but but yeah
absolutely and then you know think about
this the ads that the Suburban women are
going to see of President Trump being
locked in a jail cell while violent
criminals are you know ravaging through
cities burning down cities beating up
cops punching women and Alvin Bragg is
letting you know he he's letting 60 he's
trumping down felonies to 60 of them
he's bumping them down to Mississippi 8
000 people yeah he did the first step
back so isn't it completely ironic
in New York they released 8 000 felons
Trump's Criminal Justice Reform wasn't
like if you're a violent murderer you go
free sometimes
and then people who pled down come on
and they put down a lot of felonies as
well I mean I could pull up the first
step back good so it was it was meant it
was one it's not retroactive
and then two it was mainly targeted
towards non-violent drug offenders Alice
Marie Johnson for example was a
wonderful wonderful woman who I've
gotten to know who uh was sentenced to
almost to life in prison for having just
a little bit of drugs on her in the back
of her car but but even then if the
point were this Trump wanted a Criminal
Justice Reform and Bragg wanted Criminal
Justice Reform and then Bragg says I am
reforming criminal justice and then
Trump says I'm reforming criminal
justice and then Bragg says now I'm
going to indict Donald Trump on BS
charges that are past the statue of
limitations you're like one of these
people is lying yeah or well reforming
it doesn't always mean making it better
you can reform it into something very
horrible I mean how many of you support
the idea that you know people who get
caught with a bag of weed shouldn't go
to jail for 10 years I agree absolutely
I don't think that's what the first step
back was doing and I think that would be
grossly mischaracterizing that's what
the entire purpose of it was to be about
for non-violent drug offenders who are
treated unfairly by a corrupt justice
system who you know led by Joe Biden the
the you know the crime bill of the 1990s
you know I'm not sitting here saying we
need to let everybody out of jail but I
think there's certain cases where you
look at and like man this person is
treated unfairly and thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time